françois mitterrand en rda le chef de
l'état est arrivé ce soir à berlin est
c'est une première pour un président
français dans ce pays franz humer terran
a été accueilli par le président par
intérim monsieur manfred gerlach et par
le premier ministre hans modrow première
prise de position sur la question de la
réunification il serait très dangereux
de remettre en cause les frontières
actuelles déclarations faites par
françois mitterrand à la télévision est
allemande le chef de l'état restera en
réa jusqu'à vendredi une visite
d'ailleurs très importante pour les deux
pays la rda qui progresse chaque jour un
peu plus vite un peu mieux vers la
démocratie et la france qui préside
l'europe actuellement et qui entend bien
ne pas être absente de cette question
interallemande les enjeux de ce voyage
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux mémona
hintermann et marque doux porte de
brandebourg au côté berlin est la
souveraineté est allemande s'affiche en
attendant l'ouverture d'un passage avant
noël les partisans de la réunification
montent la garde nous sommes une seule
famille proclame la banderole et de
l'autre côté helmut kohl et un mode off
le premier ministre est allemand son
frère une constatation ici la venue de
françois mitterrand est suspecte
la position de la france n'est pas clair
avec ce monsieur est une dame ajoute la
france ne veut pas de réunification
du côté des adversaires de la
réunification aussi on reproche à la
france de se mêler de ce qui ne la
regarde pas on l'accuserait presque de
jouer un rôle de dominateur un peu comme
un astérix qui utilisera une potion
magique pour refaire l'europe à sa
manière à son image
la fraude est cette dame devrait les
églises pour l'économie l'avant de
troubles m
la politique nous pouvons vous aider
selon jean frappât non
dans une grande surface de berlin est ce
matin les clients semblent être plus
intéressés par un arrivage de lait
longue conservation que par la visite de
françois mitterrand et pour eux c'est
l'allemagne qui décide je ne voudrais
pas que toutes ont trop vite dans les
mains de qu il dise monsieur le
président de nous aider à travailler
ensemble entre l'allemagne de l'ouest et
l'allemagne laisse
moi et la caissière je n'attends pas
grand chose de la visite vous pourrez
peut-être quelque chose quand toute
l'europe sera uni
la russie la question c'est une affaire
qui nous concerne non je ne crois pas il
s'agit des allemands c'est vraiment
décidé
qu'on ne peut rien faire l'extérieur
c'est une affaire qui regarde les agents
et c'est un peuple
le contexte de la réunification se
compliquent chaque jour et le
nationalisme deviennent chatouilleux
question françois mitterrand sera
distance et d'adopter un profil bas pour
ne pas envenimer la situation
d'autres au contraire attend que le
président de la république dévoile ses
positions ce sera sans doute le cas
demain alive fiche de la révolution et
pas ici berlin est mémona hintermann est
fort